make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with heroes in
crisis part 5
this really deals more with like the
aftermath and it's almost kind of like
Superman's appeal to humanity now there
are a couple things that go on here but
again there's really really like two big
takeaways from all this there's only
really like like two big moments from
from this whole thing but I like the way
that this is done because I feel like
Tom King uses the nature of Superman so
exceedingly well so when it comes to
Superman in in DC Comics this is a very
important thing to remember here
Superman is a contextual character and
what that means is that people's
enjoyment of Superman comics is relative
to how he's written and while you would
normally say that about a bunch of other
heroes for the most part you can really
get away with a lot of things with a lot
of different heroes with Batman you can
tell really dark and gritty stories like
Batman in game and you can even go back
to Steve Englehart where the Joker was
like dark and comedic you can go into
those those different aspects Teen
Titans you can do a lot of teenage drama
or you could do happier stories there's
a lot of shifting around that goes there
but for Superman he's not really that
flexible and the reason why is because
of how long he's been around and what he
stands for
Mark Waid does it's really really good
interview years ago it was this was
probably not maybe ten years ago and
what he said was the reason why Superman
is so popular while he stands the test
of time is because he's everything to
everyone like every generation Superman
is whatever that generation needs him to
be so like during the 60s when it was
all anti Vietnam War in the hippie
movement was that it's at the height of
its popularity superman was kind of a
reflection of that he was anti-war it
wasn't it was always that way it's
always been that way with his character
that's kind of how he maintains his
relevance and so one of the worst things
you can do with Superman is try to kind
of like force him into a role that's
just not very appealing this not really
in the nature of its character but
tonking does that exceedingly well so
one of the funny things about this is
that Italy picks up with like the really
kind of the aftermath of this article
published by Lois Lane being sent out to
the world basically showing like all
these revelations and all these
statements and all these admissions and
different things like that there were
all brought to bear by the various
superheroes who were out there making
their admissions within the confines of
sanctuary and so in response to the
Superman immediately addresses the crowd
and there's a reason why it's Superman
the in universe landscape in DC Comics
Superman is the most respected superhero
on the planet right like his word is
beyond contest stations that's the
nature of his character that's the
nature of how he functions within you
know on earth within DC Comics is this
like the one guy
you don't question and there's the one
hero that like everyone has respect for
the villains respect him the heroes
respective even if they don't like him
even if they fight him all the time they
still respect him and so it makes sense
to parade him out and be the one that
basically says things because for the
most part when you're Superman shy of
somebody running up on you with
kryptonite or like doomsday not really
if you bail out they're gonna be able to
like challenge I mean the the number of
people who can legitimately challenge
Superman on earth you can probably count
on one hand and so with that being the
case it's not really like Superman is
much of a challenge and so there's not
really a whole lot for him to lose and
so he just kind of out there talking to
everybody then what he basically says is
that he's prepared a statement for this
whole thing and what he essentially says
here is that like the basis behind
sanctuary is that one he acknowledges
there was an incident then a bunch of
metahumans were killed and that the
prime suspects here are Harley Quinn and
Booster Gold of course if you guys are
curious about that feel free to watch
the previous videos but in response to
this what he basically does you know why
you have like Booster Gold and Blue
Beetle essentially like investigating
the whole crime scene which we'll talk
more about that here in a minute
Superman kind of makes this statement
and basically says the whole basis
behind sanctuary was that it was
supposed to be a place where heroes can
go to essentially recoup from all the
things they've experienced and is
basically Superman saying like these are
just people and that's kind of the cool
thing about it is because from from the
way that comic books are traditionally
written and the way the superheroes are
traditionally done they almost seem like
gods among men and for the average
person walking around it'd be different
it'd be difficult to differentiate
between the two and it's kind of a funny
thing because even Batman made that case
and the story that Tom King wrote where
you had Batman serving jury duty and he
was questioned you know Bruce Wayne was
questioning the nature of the Batman
concept is said that people call Batman
God because Batman saves them where God
does not and so if that's the case then
they have to consider Batman God because
if that's not true then how do you
justify a man that says it was this
really cool introspective look at the
character but on the whole across the
board it's usually been done in such a
way that the various superheroes save
the world from multiple threats and
humanity whether they want to admit it
or not looks to those superheroes to
save them and oftentimes forgets the
idea that they are just people that more
often than not with the exception of
Superman Martian Manhunter maybe one or
two other people that they were born on
earth and they were they were born to
parents and their parents raised them to
become productive members of society and
they were just trying to make their way
in the world as best as they possibly
can and people forget that people look
at that they just say like you're a
superhero your job is to save me and if
you don't save me it means you didn't do
your job
and the idea behind this is to say like
it was a place of recovery it was a
place of respite it was a place of the
for these people for these heroes to go
and to basically recover from the
various experiences they've had because
I can't bring that to your attention and
they can't bring that to your attention
because that shows weakness Superman I
can't get up there and and basically
start crying and showing all manner
because people will lose faith in him if
you show people that God can bleed they
will lose faith in him like that's
that's the idea behind it is that like
if Superman or one of these metahumans
got out they're sort of crying or sort
of showing vulnerability or emotion that
ultimately people would begin to lose
faith in them well if there's this week
of a person how can we rely on them to
save us how can we rely on them to be
there when the times are the absolute
toughest and so with that being the case
they needed a private place where they
could go to they could spill their
darkest secrets they could tell
everything that they ever wanted to get
off their chest and it would immediately
be deleted it would immediately be
removed and that would never really be
the case anymore it's kind of an
interesting thing because Superman even
asked that question
he says if this is a place that people
went to you if this is a place that they
went to in order to find some measure of
respite some measure of Solace does that
mean that they are now unworthy because
of the fact that they are human they do
need to find some way to let all this
steam off because they're not gods
walking on earth they're just people who
happen to have fantastic powers because
that somehow make them unworthy as it
makes them people who are are somehow
not capable of being effective you know
not only that because the fact that it
brings them back down to base level and
because of the factor that returns them
to being perceived as humans in the mind
of humanity well humans are fallible
humans screw up humans do stupid things
people say and do things all the time
that they would normally never say under
any normal circumstance but in the
height of emotion suddenly logic goes
right out the window and when that's the
case how do you in turn justify that
when you've got someone like Superman
what happens to if if Lois Lane dies as
Superman has an emotional crisis well
then you run into injustice as well as
less that's the kind of scenario that's
being presented here is what happens
when those who redeemed is infallible
with the power of God suddenly become
fallible and emotional well then
suddenly the world could be turned
upside down the world could just be left
at it's whole state of catastrophe and
that's the whole point of Superman's
making here and that's why it works so
well is because he basically says these
are people from different countries
different walks of life that I've
watched day in and day out face off
against threats that most of you guys
couldn't even imagine let alone see I've
seen them achieve and insurmountable
things I've seen them do things that
that are that are astronomical I've seen
men and women who can tap into nature
itself I've seen those who can use the
power of animals I've seen gods who
ascend
the oceans in order to try to make peace
with the surface world and literally try
to bridge the gap between these two
things I've met aliens from outer space
I've met other Kryptonians where I
thought I was alone I've met all these
different people who come from all these
different facets of what you would call
the superhero community but at the end
of the day there's still just people
they know fear they know love they know
hate they know all these emotions and
because they know all these things it's
easy to be overcome by them and that's
why it's so intriguing and that's why
it's so fascinating is because he says
that was the basis behind sanctuary it
wasn't to manipulate me it wasn't a lie
it wasn't a trick it wasn't to be a
place where they could basically say
like I killed a person and I'm
essentially performing the same act is
like you know confessing to a priest and
now it can't be used against me that's
not the basis behind it it's a place for
those individuals who have powers but
are effectively human to basically deal
with the various torments and nightmares
even do it over the course of their
entire experience in the superhero
landscape and so that's that's so
awesome because what it does is again it
kind of humanizes all these different
superheroes and I've seen a few
complaints here and there is like oh
well you know here goes DC humanizing
heroes again I mean yeah it kind of
makes sense to me unless you're saying
Batman's not human so again it's sort of
an interesting concept here to basically
see that kind of worked in and in to
kind of bring them back down because to
me I liked heroes relatable like I like
heroes who are interesting I mean for
all the complaints people will make
about DC saying we're here they go
making heroes relatable again there's an
awful lot of arguments about how
Superman sucks because he's not
relatable so I like all these different
points that are kind of being made here
and it's really really interesting but
one of the big points is also kind of
made is that Booster Gold basically says
because he's a hero who's so well-versed
in time travel
he understands the the basis behind the
rules of time-travel right like in DC
Comics you have a kind of set of
guidelines Riley you have the temporal
authority whatever it is like basically
a police force that make sure that a
person from the future doesn't get time
travel of technology and then start
screwing up the past and totally destroy
the timestream and so one of the things
Booster Gold says is that in order to
verify how far back a person's gone in
order to see whether or not a person is
actually time travel when they were
supposed to what they would do is they
would take your RNA and they would
compare it to your birthday and if your
RNA was off if your RNA was not 34 years
old and you're actually 34 years old
that's how they would know and Booster
Gold basically being kind of a shady guy
has had to essentially understand this
concept in order to find ways to work
around it and so when he and and Blue
Beetle were like investigating all these
different things what they basically
discovered here is that
the body of of Wally West is essentially
five days old that something's not right
that there's something going on in this
bigger picture things aren't really what
they seem to be now Tom King makes this
exceedingly vague he makes this
incredibly vague and he does that
intentionally because we don't really
know how this is gonna go we don't
really know where this rabbit hole leads
to but it's really intriguing and it's
actually really cool because it's one of
these things where like it's effectively
Tom King saying not everything is what
it seems to be not everything is what it
appears to be and again like as the
story goes on will essentially begin to
learn more but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]